How does Netflix's "Vikings: Valhalla" relate
to the original History series?
Is the same creative team making the sequel?
Will it be historically accurate?
Keep watching for all those answers and a
lot more.
Just when you thought you had a handle on
all the various descendants, relatives and
acquaintances of Ragnar Lothbrok, the story
of "Valhalla" jumps more than 100 years into
the future.
According to a Netflix press packet, the sequel
series begins in the year 1002, kicking off
with a "particular historical event."
That could be the Viking attack on London
Bridge led by Olaf Haraldsson in the trailer,
but historically, that event didn't take place
until several years later, if it happened
at all, so it's more likely something else.
Another candidate is the St. Brice's Day Massacre,
in which King Aethelred II ordered the slaughter
of all the Danish Vikings living in English
territory, hoping to put an end to years of
Viking raids.
Instead, King Aethelred's actions provoked
the Danish king Sweyn Forkbeard to increase
the frequency and severity of his attacks,
eventually forcing Aethelred and his queen,
Emma of Normandy, into exile.
Considering many of the main players in the
St. Brice's Day Massacre are confirmed characters
for the first season of "Vikings: Valhalla,"
it seems like a strong, dramatic contender
to kick off the series.
"The entire North is threatened."
"By the English king."
Whatever event marks the beginning of "Vikings:
Valhalla," prepare to see a significantly
more complex political landscape than in "Vikings."
In the Netflix press packet, showrunner Jeb
Stuart explains what the world will look like:
"The Vikings had been living in the British
Isles and had settled into big areas called
the Danelaw.
The Danelaw had started to grow — not just
with Danes, but also with Swedes, and Norwegians,
and folks from all over Scandinavia.
[...] Saxon nobles were afraid that, if you
went out another generation, suddenly there
wouldn't be any difference between Saxons
and Vikings."
The Vikings on "Vikings" spent most of their
time engaged in power struggles, but there
was one man in control behind the camera.
Creator Michael Hirst wrote every single episode
of "Vikings," so perhaps it's not surprising
that he'll be less involved in the sequel
series.
Hirst will still be an executive producer,
alongside "Vikings" vets Morgan O'Sullivan
and showrunner Jeb Stuart.
Stuart you may know as one of the co-writers
of "Die Hard."
"Welcome to the party, pal."
Given the time jump, we likely won't be seeing
any of the familiar faces from "Vikings,"
unless they appear as ghosts, visions, or
in flashbacks.
Fortunately, the same person who worked his
casting magic for "Vikings" is back for "Valhalla."
Frank Moiselle returns as casting director,
and has filled the new series with cast members
O'Sullivan says "bring a fresh, youthful energy
to this story."
Also back is "Vikings" historical consultant
Justin Pollard.
He will be the one digging into the obscure
history being explored by the show, working
to make sure it's as accurate as possible.
He spent months consulting with Stuart on
the new series before writing even started.
As for the shooting location, "Vikings: Valhalla"
is being shot in Ireland, just like the original
series, so there will be the same breathtaking
scenery fans expect to see.
"Vikings" had one indisputable lead character:
Ragnar Lothbrok.
"Vikings: Valhalla," though, will have three
central characters sharing the spotlight:
legendary Viking explorer Leif Eriksson, pagan
shieldmaiden Freydis Eriksdotter, and the
Norwegian prince and Viking berserker Harald
Sigurdsson.
Brother and sister Leif and Freydis will meet
Harald for the first time during the events
of the series.
Stuart says he chose to build the story around
these three characters because of what they
represent.
In the Netflix press kit, he says:
"For me, they each embody different elements
of the Viking spirit.
Bringing Leif and Freydís — who are both
Greenlanders — to Norway, to Kattegat, and
embedding them in the Viking story just seemed
a very natural place to go."
Centering "Vikings: Valhalla" around three
characters will also help offer a broader
perspective on the culture and characters,
which will be important to help modern viewers
relate to the story.
Stuart added:
"It's a timeless story.
In a strange way — if you take massive violence
out of the equation — the Vikings embody
some of the elements that we still most want
for ourselves.
[...] Our characters are dealing with relationships
and issues that are just as relevant today
as they were a thousand years ago, and those
stories will always excite and captivate us."
While some suspected that the title "Vikings:
Valhalla" meant a glimpse into the Viking
afterlife, we now know that the title of the
series isn't necessarily about that sort of
life after death.
The title "Valhalla" was chosen because the
show depicts the events that lead to the end
of the Viking Age, which historically ended
in 1066.
Stuart said:
"We played with a lot of new titles and kept
coming back to 'Valhalla' because the idea
of the show is inherently tied to the end
of this era.
It's all about showing this incredible time
in history — and how all things eventually
come to an end."
But don't get too worried just yet about the
end of the "Vikings" era.
Since the series begins in 1002, the show
has more than six decades to play around with
before the Viking Age comes to a historical
close.
And it's not like any period of history ever
came to a neat stop, so we wouldn't worry
about running out of Viking legends to dramatize
any time soon.
Frida Gustavsson will be playing Freydis Eriksdotter,
the daughter of Erik the Red and sister of
Leif Eriksson, on "Valhalla."
In an uncanny coincidence, Gustavsson's real-life
father is also named Erik, and her real-life
brother is also named Leif.
And it doesn't end there.
Gustavsson's real-life nickname is also "Freydis."
No wonder she really threw herself into her
role, reading multiple books to prepare, with
her favorite being "Valkyrie: The Women of
the Viking World."
Gustavsson was also an accomplished rider
prior to the show, giving her an advantage
during the scenes on horseback.
We can only hope she also did some strength
training, too, since Gustavsson's costume
is actually the heaviest of all the lead characters
on the show.
There are more than 2,700 hand-cut leaves
that decorate her shieldmaiden armor.
A big part of bringing the characters to life
on "Vikings" was the intricate costumes, designed
in the show's final few seasons by costume
designer Susan O'Connor Cave.
Cave is back for "Vikings: Valhalla," using
her keen eye for detail to enhance the story.
For example, while the high-necked dresses
that Emma of Normandy wears on the show are
indicative of her station and royal bearing,
they're also meant to act as her armor.
They convey that although she doesn't charge
into battle like a shieldmaiden, she's still
a warrior in her own right.
Similarly, although the devout Jarl Kåre
holds no official position in the church,
the silhouette of his costume is meant to
evoke a cassock, a garment traditionally worn
by certain Christian clergy.
Cave also incorporated the Vikings' cultural
and religious shifts into her costume designs
for "Vikings: Valhalla."
You may notice richer colors and more chainmail
in the Viking’s costumes, meant to reflect
their transition to Christianity.
Color and texture also plays a big role in
enhancing the characters, with the Greenlanders'
costumes meant to reflect their connection
to the earth, and the Vikings' costumes overall
appearing more organic, favoring wools, linens,
and furs.
The Saxons, meanwhile, will wear mostly velvets,
silks, and brocades with heavy embellishment,
highlighting the stark differences between
the cultures.
While "Vikings" developed a reputation for
playing a bit fast and loose with history,
the truth is a bit more complicated than that.
Justin Pollard served as historical consultant
on both "Vikings" and "Vikings: Valhalla,"
making him responsible for all the research
that helped inform the storylines.
But researching Viking history isn't as simple
as just referencing old texts.
As Jeb Stuart explained in his Netflix interview,
"There are a million different ways to look
at history ... We don't know a whole lot about
the original Vikings — they didn't have
a written language, so the documentation is
tricky.
They left us the sagas, but the sagas were
written 200 years after the end of this story,
and they were written by Christians.
We know archeologically what has been dug
up, but we're still discovering new things
about Viking culture."
Obviously, it's tricky to make an authentic
show about a group of people whose history
was only written down centuries after the
fact, and even then, only by people outside
their culture.
There's no simple "correct" version to defer
to, which means that many creative decisions
are based on historical interpretations rather
than historical facts.
Still, the team behind "Vikings: Valhalla"
did their best to be as true to history as
they could.
Stuart says,
"Ultimately, we've made an authentic show.
Sometimes we've moved dates or characters
around a bit, but the historical pieces are
all there."
While things did begin to shift by the end
of the series, the original "Vikings" mostly
pitted the pagan Vikings against the English
Christians, with only isolated characters
like Athelstan expressing any interest in
bridging that gap.
However, the series does feature the conversion
of the Viking warrior Rollo to Christianity,
at first in name only, but later on, in practice.
A hundred years later, the religious landscape
in Europe looked very different, with many
Vikings having followed in Rollo's footsteps
and converted to Christianity.
"Vikings: Valhalla" will explore the conflict
between the pagan and Christian Vikings, with
both sides being well represented by the Viking
families in the series.
Of its three main characters, Freydis and
Leif will both still worship Odin and the
old gods, while Harald is a Christian.
More broadly, while the Greenlander Vikings
will still be pagan, the Norwegian and Danish
Vikings will have largely converted to Christianity.
According to Stuart, the two groups will clash
in "Vikings: Valhalla" in a religious civil
war.
"Christians are my true enemy!"
"And you are mine!"
He said in the Netflix press kit,
"It's a long and somewhat complex timeline,
but when our story is set, Christian Vikings
were mostly very sincere, very tough, and
very focused on absolute and total conversion
to Christianity — or violently wiping paganism
off the map entirely."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.